[Music]
it's not hard to see that our patterns
of behavior are playing out on our
planet and it's affecting people it's
affecting people's well-being it's
affecting people's mental health Johann
Hari he says what if depression is in
fact a form of grief for our own lives
not being as they should what if it is a
form of grief for the connections we
have lost yet still needs I think more
people are on antidepressants and ever
in history and maybe that is partly
because we're so disconnected from
nature is so disconnected from natural
harmonies and ways of living and I come
to these pictures how beautiful and how
playful that everything is
interconnected like this it warms my
soul it speaks of a language that is not
spoken I don't need to say any words for
this to make mean something to people
our lungs are the lung the lungs of the
earth are the same patterns as our own
lungs and if you zoom out again we have
the same perhaps patterns and fractals
and I've shown this to people of all
ages all languages not all languages but
many languages and it speaks to them
because it speaks to our heart maybe and
not our head and my favorite patterns
spirals I shouldn't have a favorite but
I do and it's spirals because they speak
to me of time and interconnectedness in
such a beautiful way but a spiraling
fossil under the microscope and a galaxy
how beautiful we are so interrelated and
pattern can be a way one way for us to
get to that place and I think patterns
can help us break break patterns so when
patterns are broken new worlds emerge -
Lee Cooper Berg I think we are at a time
when new worlds are emerging and it's
exciting I'm now going to share a bit
more of a personal story because that's
paternity and yes that's that's
interesting and that's my kind of life's
purpose really to share this story but
about two years ago I realized I was
talking about this I was very busy I was
doing a lot I was talking about nature
connection I was talking about things
like this but actually on the inside my
life looked more like this so this is
this is actually on solstice and on
world happiness day and I had meeting
meeting meeting meeting meeting meeting
meeting meeting during a talk and then
home probably very late at night had
2,000 29,000 unread emails we've taken
on new staff we were growing the
business I didn't have any time for
myself and actually I was feeling more
like this than any natural system I was
treating myself like a cog in a machine
just endlessly doing endlessly creating
and on the surface I might have looked
like this on the left a new magazine but
on the inside this is actually how I
felt and this was me taking myself away
feeling very very burnt-out very unhappy
and very uncrated Lee fulfilled and I
took myself away to actually think this
is a place in Guatemala I went on a
silent retreat from Hunt just to kind of
recalibrate myself and I started to
ponder how we think about growth in the
West and and this I think sums it up
quite beautifully and how odds it is to
the natural world we look at growth like
this infinite line kind of fight
infinite growth on a finite planet
doesn't seem to make sense and we're not
living in this kind of emergent natural
way and I think we can go to nature to
learn a lot more about how we can live
much more live and create much more
sustainably love this Albert Einstein
quote look deep into nature and then
you'll come to understand everything
better something so beautiful about that
and I took some time and I started to
think about cycles the cycles of life
and how they are in everything this
rhythm of expansion and contraction
whether it's in the pattern of the day
our lungs the cycles of birds around the
earth the moon the tides our patterns of
sleep the patterns of life the patterns
of the movement of the planets and again
back to creativity the patterns of a
project that was actually a book that I
wrote and I did the I finished this book
and went straight on to the next project
I didn't give myself any down time and I
felt really down actually when the book
came out I felt a bit strange I hadn't
given myself space and we don't give
ourselves enough space in our Western
culture and I realized looking into it
more I was a yang yang eeper sinai'
heard this kind of term of yin and yang
but I was a Yankee person and this this
kind of sums it up quite well when you
are over yang you can cause stress on
your body and whole mental emotional
self because you're only using half your
creative cycle
namely the doing without the being and
we're very much a culture that prides
ourselves on business on doing constant
doing doing doing that's much much
better than ever resting what's what
what good is that doing anyone if we're
resting this was my screensaver for
years and I never thought about it that
much
if I started to investigate more around
yin and yang and I started to learn a
lot about nature even more it was kind
of I talked about nature and patterns
and the visual side of nature but what
about these energies that are actually
in everything in life they say this
expansion this contraction and I started
doing some research actually thanks to
Feng Shui calm I've got this fit but and
the energy of of year of Yang is here in
the white the color of white and and
it's about doing it's about expansion
it's about rising energy and it's about
it's about day it's about lightness it's
about it's about the masculine actually
it's the masculine energy and then we
have yin which is the dark we go back
into nighttime the feminine the restful
the contracted and we really start to
kind of see these energies play out as a
few more here so so yang is left brain
dominant its expression it's shaping
it's agency its asserting ourselves its
manifesting its the material it's
purposeful functional goryeo
goal-oriented and realizing your ideas
whereas yin is this much more kind of
reflective splay sits right right brain
dominant it's about co-creation it's
about relationship it's about restraint
it's about your feelings it's about
really listening it's about allowing
wholeness being connectedness and the
ineffable and I trained this time with
an amazing place called the red school
and Alexandre and my mentor is here and
I feel so happy to have her here but she
says yang reigns supreme in our Western
culture and it seems we don't have the
intuition the inner discipline or time
for the yin it's not an option to avoid
one at the expense of the other we're a
culture running on yang and that needs
to change because it's burning our
frazzling our creative brains we don't
have this we're burning out many people
are experiencing this and we're doing
exactly the same to the planet we're
seeing it like this endless resource
that we can continually
and it's not sustainable and we can
start to look at the seasons this is
something I learned the cosmology that I
learnt at the red school beautiful way
of training about women learning from
female cycles that really have so much
to tell our whole world about how we
could live more in tune with nature so
we can look to the seasons in any
creative project we have this as well so
it's worth mentioning any any creative
endeavor we do has this cycle it has
this process it has this spiraling of
energy and we start with spring at the
beginning of a project it's about
tenderness innocence curiosity
playfulness you might see how this plays
out even in a conversation that's a
creative cycle everything we do there's
cycles within cycles we have summer
that's about driving it forward it's
celebrating its high energy and its
enjoyment we all know we've got that
feeling of summer but we live in a
culture that once summer all the time
often winter autumn is about discernment
about presence insights creating space
and slowing down so in the messiness
it's the multi nurse it's the kind of
nutrients going back into the earth to
renourish the system and we have
stillness we have winter where we
withdraw we reflect we renew we rest and
we envision new ideas in nature we don't
see summer kind of constantly blooming
all the time there's time of real rest
and reflection and we need that and we
need that in our own lives and so I come
back to this this cycles these Beauty so
this is the how-to session so I thought
I'd try and take a lot of these kind of
bigger ideas and actually make something
a bit more practical as how can we start
to bring a bit more year energy into a
very yang e culture and these are very
simple there's only five but they're
about little patterns of our day where
we can start to think about this energy
of yin and yang and in everything that
we do so number one it might be taking
time in the morning for reflection and
it might be about creating space and
time for moments of daily self-care as
you move from you in that's your sleep
time into an active day of yang energy
we're doing we're getting stuff done
that's our yang so actually honoring
that transition and that cycle in every
day it might be about doing a check-in
it might be about some meditation or
just some pondering and looking at the
view it might be about not having social
media straight away in the morning you
find your cortisol levels
explode when you do that you're going
from the into yang so going softly
tuning and softly might be about gentle
music I actually spoke the Sunday Times
style and about a month ago of a piece
that are doing around around
deceleration and I talked about
sometimes not very good for the
environment so I feel bad about that but
now and again I'll have a bath before it
at the day of work and they're like
that's so radical that's so bizarre
having a bath before work but sometimes
just giving yourself that space for rest
and reflection can be really positive
and allowing you thoughts and creativity
to come through number 2 feeling first
so honoring your inner being your Yin
before going into your to-do list your
agendas your yang and a way to really
foster connection authenticity and
support so as a team at paternity we
actually always say how's everyone when
we have a meeting rather than going
straight into all our to-do lists and
things we need to get done which we all
have every day we just say how's
everyone feeling how's everyone doing
today how are we arriving how do we feel
in our body how do we feel honoring our
feelings before our thinking brains
doing yeah so checking in with others
and it really creates a real support you
might find that one person is actually
feeling really terrible but one person
feels wonderful and that can really help
you to have an almost like an ecological
system and natural system of how you're
working honoring where everyone's at the
modder bates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the institute of arts and ideas at AI TV
you